ask you are there any kids in the house
right now yes
why wouldn't there be kids in the house
i forgot how old the kids are 19 17 and
10.
yeah also the 10 so the 17 year old and
the
10 year old is at home right now correct
amanda right and the seventh year is
taking
care of the ten-year-old correct right
because she is a seven-year-old
a female she's your daughter she's my
dad yeah and the ten year let me guess
is
your son correct see your powers of
deduction you're just out and you have a
19 year old who's a son
yeah what else did google tell her no no
i didn't google i'm
this is from our last [ __ ] thing okay
i remember nothing about you
i know you don't and your son is a um
he's a wrestler very talented his
girlfriend
vietnamese girlfriend correct do you
like her
i love her oh yeah yeah yeah no she's
she's very very sweet
oh she's lovely yeah the relationship is
going very well
update for our fans yeah but it
shouldn't because she lives in texas now
oh part of me for college yeah no no no
they just moved to texas the family
moved to texas
what yeah she's going to college there
yeah but the family lives in texas
yeah you know it's his first love it's
his first love right
um hard long distance i know so does he
go over there
because yeah he's actually flying back
from there right now as we speak wow
making it work how cute because when i
was 17 18 oh my god my neck was on a
swivel yeah yeah she was thirsty
i was thirsty yeah and she did it i'll
tell you right i hear all these dudes
look at you
i hear all the stuff no i'm the last i'm
the like
you know what i am she cuz i know the
she could she generally get dates
excuse me be careful proceed with
caution but go ahead
generally dates what you're not getting
in trouble athletic
looking guys okay that's not funny right
like with guys with abs and
you know not dwarves like me i don't go
searching for them
i know i'm your first dwarf
right for the community yeah yeah she
looked at me and she went
you know these athletic guys you know i
mean they make my coochie feel good
no no they yeah yeah but then i'm gonna
go with you know
i was feeling a little bit more cherry
i'm looking for yellow clits
because this penis is like a yellow [ __ ]
you know it's like a thick it's like a
button
you know what i mean it's like smashed
you know what i mean it's small i'm with
it yeah yeah but you know what juices
come out whatever
it works yeah yeah it works you guys got
kids
no we don't yeah you don't know it works
no
we know it well we know what i i aborted
his dwarf baby
[Laughter]
wise you know i've been i've been
thinking
mike um i've been thinking about um
because i just turned 49.
yeah okay yeah yeah am i older than you
you are yes yeah yeah
it's weird huh you look so good thank
you i'm amazed
49. i'm 49. wow so um i've been telling
her i go i think i'm i think i want a
baby now
late in the day isn't it i don't think
somebody [ __ ] look at steve martin
look at steve martin yeah that's nice
i hate to say but your comedy career is
not a mountain it's a [ __ ] street
mind
okay you know steve martin can do that i
never the laughs
bobby lee i know but the last time
listen [ __ ] face the last